vous êtes sur monnet stressé vous avez
besoin de vacances monstrueuse
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue à bord
de ce vol dominèrent les listes c'est
toujours des surprises tout et c'est une
surprise mortel pour votre sécurité
merci de tes faire votre ça tient ou si
par chance une catastrophe prend donc
une dépressurisation de savoir qui veut
voir je savoure d'avancé merci
est-ce qu'on va briller dans un avion de
ligne ou pour les voler de nos propres
ailes
c'est moi qui me suis occupé tout tu
dois faire quelque chose te détendre
non
passagers nous avons entamé la descente
quelque chose pour ce week end au dessus
c'est la routine j'emmène les gamins au
foot
cette année préparez vous à vivre des
vacances monstrueuse
une croisière non non non non non non
non non non pas par attention souillées
du sein drac
il ya des activités à gogo une piscine
olympique
buffet à volonté un spa de luxe
ouais c'est très impressionnant c'est
comme un hôtel qui flotte sur l'eau
c'est ça
aucun papa merci beaucoup
non plus vive à vomir